hi paxton we heard london's in total
lockdown
we are all locked in the psychological
prison of burning aloneness how's linda
she's somewhere in the house is there
some type of issue
are fine
not only is everything not okay nothing
is okay
linda said she was planning to end our
thing
nobody wants to live alone
for two weeks we are locked together
here you know you think i'm so
happy and normal i i'd never accuse you
of being happy and normal because i'm
not
shaking i've been furloughed now there
is literally zero purpose to my life i'm
going to get provisions
we need milk bread
[Music]
how many houses have you got piss off
the nice people that i fired they were
fired because of me it's not about the
virus it's about who i
am and what i do for a living you fired
them well
thank you is that a glass of wine yes
yeah it is
we have a situation all the major
department stores are closing
they want everything over the next four
days we have a problem at harrods we
have four million dollars worth of
jewelry someone's gonna have to pack the
valuables up i believe you are a man who
can be trusted yeah i am
yeah i can be trusted it's gonna have to
be something that we trust
so that means inevitably it's gonna be
me it's a new dog what are you taking
out of harris
a diamond it's a new day
since lockdown i'm looking back at
myself like that was dead and this is
now
yeah the bastards who told me to fire
those people they are bad
you and i are
[Music]
is the most glamorous store in the world
i know all the security guards
i know the security systems
i just need to get the gentleman's name
his name
edgar allen poe edgar allan poe wow
what can go wrong lock down one last
ride
i'll load the world in heaven oh my god
give us the sin of deception
a month ago we'd be doing this not me
and i'm feeling good
[Music]
you